la dernière séance remontait au 31
janvier dernier salle comble au conseil
départemental pour voter le budget de la
collectivité pour l'année 2020
mais depuis la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus a débuté impossible donc de
tenir une assemblée en format normal
afin de respecter les gestes barrière ce
vendredi matin la séance se faisait donc
à distance c'est l'organisation des
séances dématérialisée du conseil
départemental et de la commission
permanente pendant la durée de la
d'urgence pour faire face à l'épidémie
de cofidis ne pense qu'il faut que le
pays commence à tourner mais c'est
surtout ce matin on a pris des décisions
qui sont liées directement à la crise en
particulier clan substantielle apte est
un secteur qui au plus grand que j'ai
envie de dire devant 7 millions nous on
était dans une salle à qui est conçu
pour cet exercice était avec cinq
collaborateurs même avec une distance
réglementaire ont porté le masque pas
moi parce que parler dans un micro avec
un masque
c'est un exercice quasi impossible seul
élu présent physiquement conseil
départemental à versailles pierre bédier
34 autres élus assister à la séance en
audio conférence diffusée sur la chaîne
youtube de la collectivité vote est
question se faisait donc à distance nous
allons maintenant passer la parole à
marie hélène aubert pour la wii c'est
fait merci monsieur le président bonjour
tout le monde
la séance a débuté par une minute de
silence en mémoire de patrick devedjian
le président des hauts-de-seine disparu
le 29 mars dernier du coc vide 19,73
délibérations étaient au programme de
l'assemblée qui a duré environ trois
heures à retenir à un plan daide
d'urgence de 27 millions d'euros pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire
la mise en place du pass plus les
collégiens pourront bénéficier d'une
carte est crédité de 80 à 100 euros pour
des activités extrascolaires dédiée au
sport et à la culture dans les yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine
enfin le lancement d'un groupement
d'intérêt public pour la création à
versailles et d'un centre inter
départemental du psycho traumatisme
dédié aux enfants aux retraités
ces traumatismes et donc pour ce faire
on se lance avec
christian de médecine du centre
hospitalier de versailles qui est un
spécialiste de ces questions que
pédopsychiatrie on veut se lancer dans
la création d'un groupement d'intérêt
public avec le département des
hauts-de-seine pour mettre en oeuvre des
traitements qui après qu'adapter pour
cette enfance malheureuse et maltraités
prochain rendez vous pour le conseil
départemental le 15 mai prochain avec la
commission permanente qui pourrait se
tenir cette fois-ci physiquement